to give you some examples of things that
can get done without data-target
large US store and was able to spot the
onset of the second trimester of
pregnancy from your purchases at its
store okay was that with an inky percent
degree of accuracy when you purchase
things like from you know one of them
loyalty cards that card will will will
record what you've been buying if you
have a large enough sample of data you
can then spot particular patterns okay
ed you know for example you will start
to purchase different points for your
skin you will start to pump some vet
mint supplements you start to change
your diet less alcohol more more fresh
fruit and salads you know so these are
all indicators that everybody does and
if you can do that if you in spite those
appropriate patterns you can then have a
certain amount of predictive behavior in
advance and that can a data analytics
and prediction it's starting to drive
large parts of what we do in society no
it wasn't some of that as the is the
other patterns of purchases and Huseynov
that you know actually there's a second
one which is even more interesting in
that regard and these are at one point
and this has been contained it but at
one point and claimed an algorithm which
would with a shared credit history of
two individuals who were a couple and be
able to predict divorce within two years
often before the individuals himself had
an awareness over because their spending
patterns and behaviors and started to
look like people who are orientated
towards not happening so that predictive
ability of data analytics as a big part
of what's called this the Big Data
revolution and and that ability to
protect behavior I think the issue here
is about consumer protection optimally I
don't think I don't think it's a
reasonable thing to see but
cause you didn't spend half a day
reading this document that something
Bad's happened you know that it seems
seems silly I think and and I think
companies you know need we need some
form of legislation that does us
actually what's interesting in terms of
the legislation framework that exists at
present is we're undergoing a shift were
undergoing a shift from the emphasis
been and responsibilities for these
things line with us to the line with the
data hand was to align with big business
so the EU regulations have started to
emerge have started to push those things
much more to the companies that provide
these services that's why you see that
little pop up screen saying we use
cookies because those companies are no
been comin responsible for telling you
that the danger is how we're going to
make sense about what old hope when all
of these terms and conditions all of
these issues going to get pushed artists
who made that complicated when you've
come adverse I that's a very good
question and one I wouldn't want to
necessarily be held to and I was I was
surprised that how complex kuvasz well
and given that Google's rereleased was
to simplify the terms and conditions
that surprised me and I think all of the
big sex energy companies were shocking
and particularly given that they're
meant to be a utility and they're meant
to provide information that's accessible
to all there's been a range of research
projects already which have presented
kind of different representations of
risks and exposures that you may have
that you're agreeing to and I think
they're building those and thinking of
those in terms of kind of consumer
protection models which says you know
you know nutritional warnings are one
example of us these have been mapped
over onto the digital so where you can
get simple indicators that what you're
saying in and what you're what you're
agreeing to then our gender here is
every known again my credit card company
sends me a little
Colet a bit changes to their terms and
conditions and their credit count it's
about 30 or 40 pages of the smaller
stakes that's been printed
so twenty-year-old can read it but you
know they're tight and there's loads of
clauses and things and we don't read
that but what we do read and we make
sure we read are the kind of key fact
sheets the one or two pages that were
given which says what the what the rate
of the loan is what the APR is consumer
protection advise us about these and so
thats tail of summary and key facts can
be generated for these terms and
conditions so we understand what they
aren't part of my research is trying to
understand what those are and how they
can best be presented to us so that we
understand them and I think that matters
more and more as more of what we do
actually impacts all parts of our lives
Lata Ratan is a tool of awareness so you
as an individual know have a tool to
understand the complexion I think
building those tools and exposing that
head and complexity of computing as a
critical feature for us the first thing
that has to happen is certain things
have to change
some of those changes are not computer
science there are changes of governance
changes of regulation changes of policy
those things will only happen once
people have an awareness of the issues
that involved so in some ways this is a
tool of awareness and provoke
provocation this is a tool to make
people aware that this is happening so
that pumps are the pots of public's
generally can understand this and
respond to currently this isn't a talked
about issue so that's part of what that
tools are not that tools about and other
tools that we really explore in that you
could vote would be kills which would
help present that information and more
comprehendible way tools that would
allow people to seek advice about things
and those I think are part of a family
of tools that you can build in that
space
one last question yeah have you ever run
one of your grant proposals of one of
your
emails through smoke well when we wrote
the paper upon this and what we actually
did in the conclusion was we did two
things we run our own people through it
and found that we were at a tertiary
level of education there was an academic
paper that seemed reasonable but rather
and yes rather more frivolously perhaps
we also run the terms of conditions of
the conference that we were submitting
the proposal to and found that that was
also at every level of education always
seemed reasonable but it's an obvious
thing to feel that you need to do